fluorescence activated cell sorting is a
very useful technique for cell biologist
and immunologist there is wide variety
of application for facts such as cell
cycle analysis cell viability analysis
it can be used for multi-ohmic analysis
and clinical diagnosis in the facts
there is a fluidic system which channels
cells in a streamlined fashion now a
laser hits this cell while it passed
through the stream and the scattered
lights are detected by a forward or a
side scatter detector
and entire data is projected to the PC
where we can understand and see the
plots so forward scatter is a measure of
size it is proportional to size and the
side scatter is proportional to the
complexity or granularity of the cell
now let's try to understand the facts
data in this particular population you
can see a cell which is much bigger and
granular compared to this particular
population using this technique one can
understand the different type of blood
cells and their cohorts the composition
of blood
full video is available in this link